the truth is these foods are designed to
be over consumed and without telling
consumers how these foods are gonna you
know affect their behavior when they try
to moderate their consumption of these
pita chips or the pint of ice cream and
they end up feeling moral failures
because they just simply can't that I
think is where the problem lies that
know that Alzheimer's and dementia that
these numbers seem to be increasing and
increasing and your mom you said 59 she
was 58 50 years old I mean that's
incredibly young so let's talk about
some of those things that you can do
before they before you're sitting at the
doctor's office and they're giving you
the ten medications yeah I mean the
first thing that you need to realize is
that dementia often begins in the brain
decades before the first symptom and I
saw that nobody was talking about this
and that's why I decided to step up you
know I it didn't the fact that I wasn't
a medical doctor to me didn't seem like
a barrier to entry because I genuinely
believe that people should know how to
care for their bodies and their brains
and we're just not taught this we're fed
misinformation from every conceivable
angle whether it's the food industry and
the way that they market their foods
making health claims on their products
to the way that the media reports on on
health studies and and research and
things like that so I think I mean what
I've learned is that you really that the
the standard American diet is toxic
essentially and anything that you could
do to run in the opposite direction of
that so what is the standard American
diet if you're paint in that picture
yeah what does that really look like
there are I mean there are images that
you can like you can go to Google Images
and you can search for the average you
know shopping hall for your typical
American family over the course of the
week and essentially it's all processed
foods ultra-processed foods to be to be
more clear today 60 percent of the
calories that we're consuming come from
what are called ultra ultra processed
foods which are made in factory is they
usually are the processed permutations
of wheat corn and rice maybe some soy
and they generally are what food
scientists refer to as being hyper
palatable so
they they're extremely calorie dense
they're not satiating in fact they
actually can make you hunger yeah hungry
later on I mean they often put additives
in there right that actually make you
want more right isn't that the Dorito
effect or something well I think it's
the fact that I mean these foods are
just they're there they become
impossibly delicious when you combine
sugar fat salt you know these are I mean
each of these flavors were relatively
scarce in antiquity and today they're
just abundantly available like sugar
would be available to a hunter-gatherer
you know once per year when it was
summer and the fruit you know became
ripe and even then the the fruits that
would be available to one of our
ancestors would be a fraction as sweet
as they are today right right the amount
of apples that you would have to eat to
get the sugar levels that you could get
in a bag of Sour Patch Kids or something
yeah like the ancestral Apple is like a
crabapple actually and today there you
know we have like these cosmic Crisp
apples that are amazing like don't get
me wrong I'm a huge fan of apples but
they're bred to contain more starch and
sugar than ever before and in history
and they're also bred a lot of our
produce now is being bred to remove
these bitter compounds which are
actually compounds that probably produce
the greatest health benefit when we
consume them like polyphenols and
flavonoids and things like that so sugar
fat we know is is highly delectable you
know I mean it sends off our you know
brain's reward centers like it's one of
the reasons why we put half-and-half in
our coffee it just allows flavors to
linger on the tongue and in salt you
know the word salary derives from salt
it was uh it was something that was it's
super important you know we need it for
good health sodium is a macro mineral
it's also one of these nutrients has
been demonized over the past couple of
decades but you combine them all
together and it's basically like the
fourth of July is you know fireworks in
the brain and it makes it impossible to
moderate our consumption of these foods
and so one of the one of the ideas that
I put forth in the genius laughs I try
to really make dietary recommendations
without further harming people's
relationship with food I think people
today have this fractured relationship
with food yeah I always see what when
I'm at Trader Joe's they have guilt-free
pita chips and I'm always like the fact
that the world the word guilt is on
there yeah like like the idea that you'd
be buying a regular pita chip and feel
guilty about it is kind of crazy putting
aside whether you want carbs or breads
or whatever but like the way it's all
marketed guilt these are guilt free
right like so you can walk out here and
you're not gonna feel guilty like yeah
that's not the stuff you should feel
guilty over no it's ridiculous I mean
the truth is these foods are designed to
be over consumed and without telling
consumers how these foods are gonna you
know affect their behavior when they try
to moderate their consumption of these
pita chips or the pint of ice cream and
they end up feeling moral failures
because they just simply can't mm-hmm
that I think is where the problem lies
on the other hand if you actually are
aware that these foods you know they're
so easily over consumed then it becomes
informed consent you know then you
actually know what you're opting into
and then there shouldn't be any guilt
about that you're just making you're an
adult making a decision which you should
be able to do it you should be able to
eat whatever you want but the problem is
I think that most people don't know that
these foods actually drive
overconsumption there was a great study
that was published and I wrote about
what these hyper palatable
ultra-processed foods do to our behavior
ingenious foods but since genius foods
came out there was a great study that
was published it actually was funded by
the National Institutes of Health and
they found that when people were given
all-you-can-eat access to an ultra
processed diet it's called ad libitum
feeding that people tend to over consume
about 500 additional calories to reach
the point of satiety so to just eat
until to a point of fullness people tend
to over consume about 500 calories a day
and you're more inclined to do that by
eating processed with these Ultra bagels
muffins pizzas burritos chicken dishes
potato chips sandwiches things like that
you know the foods that are that are
primarily packaged shelf-stable devoid
of moisture which actually can can be
satiating when food has water in it but
you know water is it makes food spoil it
did like you have to remove the water to
make a product shelf-stable so they're
not satiating they can often induce
what's called biphasic hunger so they
can make you hungry later on
yeah 500 additional calories of day that
a day that might not seem like a lot but
stretched out over the course of a week
that's a pound of fat game hmm
and then they so it was a crossover
study and when they put these same
people when they gave them access to
foods that were minimally processed
again ad libitum feeding they were able
to eat until they were full to the same
degree of satiety they actually under
consumed about 300 calories a day so
what that's gonna do is lead to
effortless weight loss so that's really
kind of like the switch that I think
people need to people need to be aware
of that yeah you know we took we tend to
think that we have full agency when it
comes to our meal choices but we don't I
mean where our actions are the end
result of an interplay between hormones
neurotransmitters which are ultimately
influenced by the types of foods that
we're eating do you think more than
anything else though you're always as
someone that cares about this and you're
trying to get people to change their
habits it's really always about fighting
a marketing machine that is oddly ahead
of you so like if you just turn on
television and every commercial you see
for like a breakfast food suddenly they
try to make everything healthy but you
know it's like an egg that you crack in
this thing and then it's got all this
other stuff already in there and it
sorta seems healthy you're kind of like
oh I'm eating an egg in the morning and
it kind of seems right and then I'm sure
that when you look at the instructions
or the ingredients on the back it's like
yeah the sodium and everything else but
but you have to fight that costly
because they're marketing it all as
healthy yeah I mean food marketing it's
a you know they put products at eye
level they mark it's children you know
they get those they've they've forged
those habits early in life they become a
you know exponentially more difficult to
break but yeah I mean I think it's I'm
human
so I processed foods too right like I'm
just as guilty as anybody else but I
think to be aware I mean knowledge is
power at the end of the day and to be
able to act on that knowledge I mean
that's the most empowering aspect of all
of this because you know like health is
something that health care is something
that we that we do when we're like
pushing the shopping cart through the
you know the aisles of the supermarket
are actually avoiding the aisles because
that's where all the ultra-processed
foods tend to tend to be and you know
when we're debating with ourselves
whether or not to get to the gym
that's really
where healthcare happens what I
experienced with my mom was sick care
and the relative lack of options once
you actually have one of these like
chronic diseases that has set in and so
at the end of the day the food industry
doesn't have your back I mean the food
industry is great in many it's not the
industry like it's all bad I mean yes
food is safer right you know where we're
exposed if you were pathogens than ever
before
you know the hunger is less of an issue
today than it is in the past if you're
in the developed world the developed
world but a lot of these conditions that
were seeing society now struggle with
her lifestyle mediated their mediated by
being you know overly sedentary by
basing our diet around these ultra
processed foods and you know it's funny
I'm noticing now at Whole Foods just
because we're in the midst of this odd
thing with coronavirus that nobody at
least at my Whole Foods nobody's
touching the grains that you can do
yourself you know they've got a wall of
grains it's like nobody's even going
over there anymore which is proud I
guess good at the moment but yeah a lot
of people are now using these hand
sanitizers if you like go on Amazon it's
there the the markup has just shot up
exponentially but something that I think
few people appreciate is that when you
use a hand sanitizer before you go
shopping and then you touch the store
right just to receive these store
register receipts are actually coated
with bisphenol A which is a pretty
potent endocrine disruptor that hand
sanitizer when you use it just before or
even just after you touch these receipts
that actually dramatically by at least
an order of magnitude increases the
permeability of your skin to these
compounds if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell